The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
So radioactive decay
is kind of a classic example
of a first-order process.
So we are doing one
little tiny section
of the chapter on
nuclear chemistry,
and we're doing that all today.
And so all we're really
covering is problems associated
with first-order processes.
So this is just a small
introduction to this idea.
So radioactive decay has
a lot of applications.
There are medical applications,
including imaging organs
and bones, including the heart.
And so there is a compound
that you already saw
called Cardiolite.
And so we talked about
this in transition metals
because you have a
transition metal.
And what is the geometry
of this compound?
Octahedral, and we have
cyanide ligands, which
what kind of field strength?
Strong.
Yeah.
So this compound
was designed in part
by an MIT professor,
Alan Davison.
You could go talk to him about
this incredible discovery
and invention.
It's used about seven
million times a year
or to image various organs and
has been for a very long time.
It's off patent now.
But this patent made Allen
Davison, MIT, and MIT Chemistry
Department an enormous
amount of money.
And so you could go
talk to him about it,
except he's happily retired
living in one of his homes.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can't really do that.
But anyway, so this uses
an isotope of technetium,
which is metastable isotope.
And so it's 99.
It's an isotope of the
normal 98 atomic mass.
And so the next
challenge, you're
always looking for
the next great thing,
the next great imaging agent.
So this is still a very
active area of research,
and there's actually a talk just
this week on campus about work
in this area.
So this is transition metals
combined with radioactivity.
So it's two topics
here in the class.
So another, of
course, important use
is the potential
of nuclear energy
and the current use
of nuclear energy.
This has many
challenges, and I don't
want to go on record of what
I think about nuclear energy.
I think it's a
complicated problem.
There are a lot of challenges.
But one I'd like to
bring up, because I think
it's particularly
interesting to me,
is what to do with the waste.
And so one story that I
heard about actually there
was a documentary
made about this.
Finland had this idea to create
this three-mile long tunnel,
and they wanted to store 12,000
metric tons of nuclear waste.
And they wanted the containers
to store it for 100,000 years.
And this documentary asked
a number of questions
about this idea, such as, what
kind of container do you use,
and how do you know the material
you design your container is
going to last 100,000 years?
As experimental
scientists, we like
to test how long things last.
But you can't really
do this experiment.
Also, it kind of
brought up the idea,
do you guard this facility
for 100,000 years?
Because you can make bombs out
of a lot of this radioactive
waste.
So you kind of
need to protect it.
But maybe you
should just bury it
and then no one knows
it's there so you
don't have to guard it so
they can't find it and use it.
But then what if
someone stumbles upon it
and releases all of
this radioactivity?
So that would be bad.
So do you put warning
signs for people
who will be around 100,000 years
from now, saying, hey, don't
go in here.
It looks like a pretty tunnel.
But, hey, the half-life
of the thing stored here
are 100,000 years.
So this is pretty
radioactive still.
Don't go inside.
And if you write this sign,
what language do you put it in?
So the documentary pointed
out that Neanderthals
existed like 40,000 years ago.
So 100,000 years from now,
what's going to be going on?
How do you write a sign to
people that long in the future?
Anyway, I just think that these
are sort of interesting ideas
and brings up the point that
as scientists and engineers,
we need to think not
only about the science
and engineering of
what we're doing,
but the ramifications to
society and the sociology
as well as politics involved
in some of this science.
So this is an interesting
area for that intersection
of the social sciences
and the natural sciences
and engineering.
So radioactive
decay-- definitely
a useful thing, dangerous and
useful all at the same time.
Oh, look at that.
You know the clicker
question's coming up
at the bottom of the page.
We're not there yet.
It's OK.
I just added that at
the end and apparently
didn't animate it well.
So the decay of a nucleus is
independent of how many nuclei
are around it.
That's what makes it
a first-order process.
So because it's a
first-order process,
we can apply those first-order
integrated rate laws
that we just derived.
So we had our rate log of the
concentration of something
A equals its original
concentration
to the e to minus k, which is
our rate constant times time
and also our half-life
equation that we just used.
So instead of
concentration of A,
though, we're going to
have a different thing
to express what we're
interested in here, which
is N, the number of nuclei.
So we can just write that
same expression down.
But instead of
concentration of A,
we're just going to
use capital N. So
N, the number of nuclei
at some particular time,
equals how many nuclei were
present originally times e
to the minus k.
And here it is a
rate constant still,
but it's a decay constant in
that the rate you're measuring
is radioactive decay.
So it kind of has
a special name.
Although, if you use
rate constant for that,
that is what it
is, so that's OK.
t is still time.
And yes, N to the o is the
original number of nuclei.
So we're just going to
do a clicker question
about how one goes
about calculating
the number of nuclei.
10 more seconds.
So someone want to tell me
for one of the Green Lantern
T-shirts, what is wrong
with the other answers?
I think I saw your
hand up first.
Sorry, folks.
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
So answers one
and two, they have
the wrong-- what was it--
the molar mass of technetium.
Is that technetium?
Yeah And answer four does not
multiply by Avogadro's number.
So that's going to give
you the number of moles
of the particle.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Right.
Great job.
It's Thanksgiving.
I thought we needed
a good prize today.
So right.
So one thing you
also want to remember
make sure that your
units are good.
And it's really
important in doing
this-- you can take
this back-- to remember
to use the number that is here,
this atomic mass number, not
the one from the periodic table
in calculating the problem.
Actually, the periodic
table disappeared from that.
Oh, well.
So if you use the periodic
table, it's a close answer
but sometimes.
Sometimes it won't be so close.
But remember, when it tells
you about the isotope,
it always has the
atomic mass that you
should be using in the problem
as part of the questions.
So keep that in mind.
And yeah, you definitely want
to remember Avogadro's number.
And the answers
are such that it's
hard to tell that you messed up.
With the wavelength,
it's really easy
to tell you messed up if you
didn't use Avogadro's number
because it doesn't
make any sense.
With these, it's
a little harder.
So remember to use the
isotope's atomic mass
and also remember to
use Avogadro's number
when doing this.
And then you should be fine.
So this is really similar.
It's really similar,
depending on whether you're
talking about chemical
kinetics or nuclear kinetics
in doing these problems
in terms of the equations.
But in chemical kinetics, you're
measuring the concentration.
Whereas with nuclear kinetics,
you're measuring decay events.
And so usually how do
you measure decay events?
And the most common way is
here, our Geiger counter.
So I just want to-- it's
always important every once
in a while at MIT
to double check
that the rooms that
you're teaching in
have not been contaminated by
some wonderful experiments.
So, so far, we're good.
So here, this is working.
You can hear the chips, I think.
This is pretty good.
You don't have to be
concerned about this.
There's always some
background level.
It's fine.
So there are gases in
here that will get ionized
by radiation, which gives off.
Then that's translated
into that clicking noise.
So that's what is happening.
So it's measuring,
with our thing,
whether there are any
radioactive events going on.
And this is called
a Geiger counter.
And we use X-rays in my lab.
So I went and stole this
from our X-ray facility
before I came here.
Luckily, it's
almost Thanksgiving,
so no one was
collecting any data.
So no one will get in trouble
for taking this right now.
And Hans Geiger is
the person who came up
with this idea and this device.
Does anyone remember where
we heard that name before?
Think back class two.
So he did that amazing
gold foil experiment.
And so our ping pong balls
that we were throwing
were duplicating the
experiment that he
did as a graduate student.
And luckily, I think
he was smart enough
to realize that when you're
working with things--
he was working with a lot of
radioactivity at that point--
that once you know exactly
how much radioactivity you're
working with-- and so these
were very early day experiments.
And he came up with
this device that helped
him know how safe he was.
And this is still sort
of the standard thing
to have these around and
double check that there
is no radiation leaks
in places like that.
So the Geiger
counter-- all right.
So also a couple of
more terminology things.
Decay rate is also called
activity or specific activity.
So you're talking about how
active your substance is.
That's really how
radioactive is it.
And activity also
has the letter A.
So we were talking about
the concentration of A.
Now we have A again.
There's a lot of
A's in this unit.
So that's the change now in
the number of nuclei over time-
that's the rate expression,
or the rate law-- k,
the decay constant, times
the number of nuclei.
And because activity is
proportional to the number
of nuclei, we can also
take this expression
that we had before
that had the N's in it
and rewrite it with A.
So now it's really just like
that first-order expression
we had but without the
concentration term.
So we have the activity
at some time equals
the original activity
of the material times
e to the minus kt.
And all of these
equations are going
to be on your equation sheet.
But if you mess up and use
the wrong equation for this,
it doesn't matter,
as long as you're
using the first-order equation.
Whether it's
concentration or activity,
it's the same idea
that you can determine,
if you know the rate constant
or the decay constant,
how much material is left,
how much activity is left,
how many nuclei are left
after a given amount of time.
So I know what you're
all thinking now.
You're thinking,
this is fantastic,
but what about the units?
We musts here about the units.
So the SI units for activity
are the becquerel, BQ.
And one becquerel is one
radioactive disintegration
per second.
And this is the newer unit.
The older unit was
called a curie,
and sometimes you will still
see this in the literature.
And a curie, one
curie, was 3.7 times 10
to the 10th
disintegrations per second.
So it was a much larger number
than the current SI unit.
So this was what one gram of a
radium specific activity was.
So they used this big number.
But it was not really
practical because you
want to tell people like how
much radiation would be safe
for them to have in a year
or something like that.
And you didn't want to use
this giant number for that.
So we've moved to here.
So does anyone know or want to
guess who the older unit was
named for of radioactivity?
One might think Marie Curie.
But a lot of the
evidence suggests
it was actually her
husband, Pierre Curie,
who it was named after.
It's a bit controversial.
But they both worked
together, and they
worked with Henri Becquerel.
And they all won
the 1983 Nobel Prize
for discovering radioactivity.
Three years later, Pierre Curie
was killed crossing the street.
He slipped when it was raining,
and a horse and wagon, I guess,
ran over him and killed him.
So this is, I think, an example
of someone who's so brilliant,
but you say, they're
so brilliant,
but do they look both ways
before they cross the street?
So you are all very brilliant.
And I encourage
you look both ways
before you cross the street.
Anyway, so he died.
And some of the stories are that
they named the unit after him
as a tribute.
Others say, well, it's
really for both of them.
But in any case, now it's
named after the third person,
Henri Becquerel.
So radioactivity,
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about
radioactivity.
This chart is not
in your handout
because you're not
responsible for knowing
all this information, so I
just didn't put it in there.
But you can look this up.
There's a couple of
points I did make
in your handout,
which is there are
different types of
nuclear radiation.
We have alpha particles, alpha
decay, beta decay, gamma decay.
Some of those involve
a mass change.
So like an alpha particle is
the same as a helium-4 nucleus--
two protons, two neutrons.
Beta decay involves an electron.
Gamma is a photon.
So there are definitely
different types.
Some mass change, some not.
There are also really dramatic
differences in half-life.
So again, half-life depends
on the material in question.
It depends on that decay
constant, that rate constant.
And if we look at this
table, we can see things
from milli seconds.
And if we look at some
of these, d is for a day.
a is for year.
y is also for year.
So sometimes you'll
see y for year.
Sometimes you'll see a.
I think most people guess
that y is for a year.
That a is for year,
I don't really know.
But anyway, in
this table it's a.
So if you see that,
don't be confused.
And Ga, that's giga
years, so 10 to the ninth.
That's where the
Finland 100,000 years
comes from, that we need to
keep the stuff safe for a very,
very, very, very, very,
very long amount of time
for giga years.
So in some decay processes,
such as uranium-238,
you have more than one type
of nuclear radiation going on.
And it can involve a very
long and complicated series
of different events.
So here at MIT, we spend
most of our time talking
about science and engineering.
But I feel like
every once in a while
we should throw in some poetry
into our science classes.
So once a year I like
to read a chemistry poem
to enrich our lives.
And today is that day in 2014.
And the poem I'm
going to read to you
is called "The Days
of Our Half-Lives,"
and it is by Professor
Mala Radhakrishnan.
She got her PhD here at MIT
in the Chemistry department.
And she wrote this book, which
she wanted me to point out
is available on Amazon if you're
looking for a Christmas present
for a very, very
geeky friend of yours.
And it's illustrated by
another MIT chemistry
PhD, Mary O'Reilly, who
actually did the illustrations
for the videos that I've
been showing you in class.
So MIT chemists, just really
multi-talented individuals.
So I will read
you this poem now.
And as I read it to
you, I will point out
what is happening in
this decay process
because all of Mala's poetry
is scientifically correct.
So "Days of Our Half-lives."
"My dearest love, I am
writing you to tell you
all that I've been through.
I've changed my whole identity.
But loved, I can't
pretend to be.
When I was uranium-238,
you were on my case
to start losing weight.
For 5 billion years I'd
hoped and I'd prayed,
and finally I had
an alpha decay.
Two protons and two neutrons
went right out the door.
And now I was thorium-234.
But my nucleus was still
unfit for your eyes,
not positive enough
for its large size.
But this time my half-life
was not very long,
because my will to change
was really quite strong.
It took just a month, not even
a millennium, to beta decay
into protactinium.
But still, rejected me right off
the bat-- protactinium, who's
heard of that?
So beta decay I did once
more to become uranium-234.
Myself again but a new isotope,
you still weren't satisfied.
But I still had hope.
Three alpha decays
'twas hard, but I
stayed on through thorium
then radium and then radon.
I thought that I would
finally please you.
My mass was a healthy 222.
But you said, although
I like your mass,
I don't want to be
with a noble gas.
They dress so well.
You had a point though.
I wasn't reactive.
So in order to please
you, I stayed proactive.
A few days later, I found
you and said, two more alpha
decays, and now I am lead.
But you shook your head.
You were not too keen on
my mass number of 214.
I had a bad experience
with that mass before,
and an unstable astatine
walked right out the door.
So in order to
change, I went away.
But all I could do
was just beta decay.
My hopes and my dreams
started to go under,
because beta decay does
not change a mass number.
To bismuth and polonium,
I hoped and I beckoned.
My half-life was 1
6 4 microseconds.
And then finally,
I alpha decayed.
And then I was lead with a
prize worthy mass of 210.
Got to admit, I was
getting quite tired,
and my patience with
you had nearly expired.
You were more demanding
than any I'd dated.
And much of my energy
had been liberated.
But you still weren't
happy, but you had a fix.
I really like the number 206.
So I waited for
years until the day
which began with another
beta decay and then one more.
And finally, in
the end, I alpha-ed
to lead 206, my friend.
To change any further.
I wouldn't be able-- not longer
active, but happily stable.
It took me a
million years to do,
but look how I've changed,
and all just for you.
Wait, what did you say?
I've gotten so old
that you'd rather
be with a young lass of gold?
Well, I give up.
We're through, my pumpkin.
Shouldn't all my effort
be counting for something?
Well, you won't be able
to rule me anymore,
because I'm leaving you
not for one atom, but four.
That's right.
While you were away
diffusing, I found
some chlorines that I
found quite amusing.
And we're going
to form lead, Cl4,
and you won't be
hearing from me anymore.
See, over the years,
I've grown quite wise.
I've learned that
love's about compromise.
You still have half
of your half-lives
to live, so go out there.
It's your turn to give."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
There's a whole book
of them on Amazon.
So that is first order.
First order is pretty exciting
because it has nuclear decay.
Second order-- not
quite as exciting.
But we should talk
about it anyway.
So second order
integrated rate loss--
we're not going to go
through a derivation.
It's in your book.
But here is the equation,
if you do the derivation.
So now we have 1 over the
concentration of A at time t
equals rate constant
k times t plus 1
over the original
concentration of A.
And we could plot this one over
concentration of t versus time.
And if we did that, you
would have the opportunity
for another clicker question.
10 more seconds.
90s, yeah-- it's kind
of hard to come up
with clicker questions
in this unit, so.
But it's fun, for Thanksgiving,
we'll have lots of 90s.
So we can just look, and this
is actually an expression
for a straight line again.
So we're plotting on the y-axis
one over a concentration of A
at all the various different
times versus time over here.
And so our intercept
is going to be
1 over the initial
concentration of A.
And our slope is
going to be what?
k, right.
So again, you can measure
your concentration
as it changes with time, how
the concentration changes,
plot it, and just determine
your rate constant
for that particular material.
So second order half-life--
we can do another derivation.
But in this case, I will
just give you the equation.
So half-life equals
1 over k times
your original
concentration of A.
And so this is different
from first order.
There is a concentration
term in the equation.
So for second
order half-life, it
does depend on the
starting concentration.
So that's really
the big difference.
In first order,
it doesn't depend
on the starting concentration.
It just depends on the rate
constant or the decay constant,
which depends on the
material in question.
With second order,
you do need to know
how much you had originally.
So again, how do you know if
it's a first or a second order
process?
And here, you really have to
determine it experimentally.
So one thing you
could do is measure
how A changes over time and
then plot your data using
the equation for first order.
And you may see that,
yeah, that does not
form a straight line
when you're plotting
with natural log of
a concentration of A.
But then if you try plotting it
1 over the concentration of A,
you get a beautiful straight
line with your data.
And so you'd say, that's
a second-order process.
So again, you're determining
these things experimentally,
collecting data,
plotting the data,
determining rate
constants, determining
the order of the reaction.
Now, this is very exciting.
What we're going to talk
about is the relationship
between the rate constants
and equilibrium constants.
So I love this.
I love when we
come back to stuff
that we've talked
about before and see it
in a slightly different way.
So at equilibrium,
we talked about how
it's a dynamic process.
And you have the rate
of the forward reaction
equal the rate of
the reverse reaction.
Reactions are still going.
They haven't stopped.
But the rates are equal
in both directions.
So we've talked about how
to write an equilibrium
constant for reaction.
So if we have a reaction of
A plus B going to C plus D,
we can write our equilibrium
constant k and its products
over reactants.
Unless one of our
products or reactants
is a solid or a very
dilute solution.
It's the solvent.
And I heard from your TAs
that in the last problem set,
some people had forgotten what
goes into q or k expressions.
So it's good to review that for
this next unit and exam four
and the final-- so
products over reactants.
Now suppose we
tell you that it's
a second-order process and the
rate of the forward reaction
here, A plus B, we
can write the rate
law for that forward
reaction being
second order, first order
in A and first order in B.
So the rate constant for
the forward direction
is k 1 and then times the
concentration of A times
the concentration of B.
For the reverse reaction, the
rate constant is k minus 1.
And this is generally
true in all the problems.
If it's a first step, you have
plus 1 k1 on the top, k minus 1
on the bottom.
So we have k minus 1 times
the concentration of C and D
So that's the
backward direction.
So at equilibrium,
these rates are equal.
We just talked about that.
We've seen that before.
The rate of the forward
reactions, so k1 times
A times B is equal to k
minus 1 times C times D
when you're at equilibrium.
So we can rearrange
this equation now
and say C and D over
here over divide
by A and B. It's going to be
equal to k1 over k minus 1.
And we also just saw that
C times D over A times B
was equal to k.
So therefore, our equilibrium
constant k equals k 1,
the rate constant for
direction, over k minus 1,
the reversed direction.
So here we're relating
equilibrium constants and rate
constants.
So we thought a lot
about what's true
if you have a big
equilibrium constant.
If you have a big
equilibrium constant,
if you have an equilibrium
constant much greater than 1,
what's the ratio of products
and reactants at equilibrium?
Is there more or less products
at equilibrium and reactants?
More.
So we thought about
that, and now we
can think about the relationship
of the rate constants.
So if k is greater than 1,
is k 1 greater or less than k
minus 1?
Greater.
And so that would
then be the case
where you have more products
than reactants at equilibrium.
If k is less than
1, a case where
there's more reactants than
products at equilibrium,
then you have k 1 is
less than k minus 1.
So again, we can
think about this
in terms of thermodynamics.
We can also now think
about it in terms of rates.
So one more thing that we need
to cover before we end today,
and that is about elementary
steps and molecularity,
which I just love
saying that word.
So on Monday,
we're going to talk
about mechanism of reactions.
Most reactions do not
occur in one step,
and we need to think
about mechanisms.
I said it was Wednesday.
But it's actually Monday.
So it's coming up.
It's very exciting.
And we're going to talk a
lot about elementary steps
when we talk about mechanisms.
So an elementary step is one
of the steps in the reaction.
So reactions usually
don't occur in one step.
They have many
steps, and each step
is called an
elementary reaction.
So we talked about last time
that for the overall order
of the reaction, you can't
just look at the stoichiometry
and say what the order
of the reaction is.
So you can't predict
it from stoichiometry
for an overall reaction.
But if it's an elementary
reaction, if it's a step,
that elementary reaction is
written exactly as it occurs.
So in that case, the order and
the rate law can be predicted.
So this is you're
breaking it down
into sort of the smallest
unit, the smallest
step, this elementary
reaction, so you can just
look at the stoichiometry
for a single step,
for an elementary
reaction, and project
to the order and the rate law.
So elementary reactions
occur exactly as written.
So that's what we're
going to do on Monday.
We're going to break
down our mechanisms
into elementary steps,
write out the rate laws,
and then figure out what kind
of mechanism we might have.
So finally, molecularity--
so molecularity
is just the number of
things that come together
to form a product.
And here we have three names--
unimolecular, bimolecular,
and termolecular.
Unimolecular process,
what do you guess?
How many reactants are coming
together to form product?
One.
Bimolecular, what do you guess?
Two.
Termolecular is a little harder,
but just give it a whirl.
Three, yes.
So bimolecular is very common.
And termolecular is not.
So I have three molecules
to come together.
And if you try to
think about how
you get three things to come
together all at the same time,
that's kind of rare.
Usually, when there are
three things reacting,
there are multiple
steps involved.
But two is good.
Now finally, we'll end
with a clicker question.
Think about which of
these would be examples
of unimolecular processes.
10 seconds.
So it actually is one and two.
So most people got the two.
Yes, that's radioactive decay.
But the other, you can
have a decomposition.
So here we have decomposition
into its elements
is also a first-order process.
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
See you next Monday.